>> Well, can you give us a 4,000 foot view of what LayerBlox is?
>> So, LayerBlox is a software generator for
generating different variants of products in the same product line.
>> So you, you want to be able to generate all of these, these variants.
how, how how does your generator actually work?
What does it take as input, and, and and, and, and how does it process that?
>> That's a good question.
So I should say first off that our generator is based on
a pretty well understood idea from software engineering.
That goes back to, really goes go back to the,
the early 90s on product line generation.
And so, each variant that we want to
generate is a different program in the same product line.
And we, we organize our product lines in terms of
re-useable features that we put into a library.
We've designed them according to a design idiom that, that, that makes them
very composable with one another, which I'll demonstrate here in a little while.
And what you do, then, to,
to generate a variant is you write something called an assembly specification.
Assembly specification explains how you put these features together in
some novel combination to generate a particular variant.
And it has some particular useful properties, which I think we'll be able to,
to dig into by example here in a few minutes.
But what's really nice about it is the features you can write once and
reuse many times.
And you can very easily understand by virtue of
comparing these assembly specifications how two different variants in the same
product line are common and how they differ and be very precise about that.
>> And I'm curious about the, the title, LayerBlox.
Is it, is this related to layered architectures?
>> It is, it is.
When you see some examples of assembly specifications,
you'll see that the, the components that we're generating, each component,
when I use the term variant, I mean program or component.
So the when you see how, how a given component is generated,
you'll notice that it's, the little program you write to say how to generate it,
the recipe looks, is, is a very layered, very hierarchical form.
It's related to layered architectures in another way too,
in the sense that typically with layer architectures,
you tend to think of of software built in stacks.
Where you can understand a layer you can understand one layer,
just in terms of the interface that it exports, without any
knowledge of how it's implemented or of the layers that are underneath it.
the, the assembly specifications that we write using LayerBlox have
that same property.
>> And, and just to, to clarify a bit.
The layers that you're talking about are, and
the generated code you're talking about, they go in that middle tier?
>> No, they actually, in this case they could go in the middle tier.
But in this case they go in, down in the data tier.
>> Okay, so the, the tiering is kind of independent of the, of the layering?
>> That's correct.
That's correct.
>> And in the diagram, there's also this reusable feature library.
Can you say a word about that?
>> So, you know, I mentioned earlier that when we have a number of
different clients, their programs and their applications are very similar, but
they're not exactly the same.
What we found is that if we do a decomposition and
design of our software by feature and I
know you guys have spoken of feature diagrams and feature modeling in the past.
When you, when you when you do a feature-based design,
you actually can get reusable pieces of, they're not whole applications.
They're little fragments, but the, but
they're highly reusable and composable in ways that you can put them together to
make different variants of a, of, of the same application very easily.
So we did a,
in the example we'll see we basically did a feature analysis to understand what
are the different features that are put together to do forecasting.
And based on that feature analysis,
we we designed our reusable features around it and,
and got this ability to, to, to compose them in this very, very nice way.
>> So the, the unit of variation is kind of, a customer-visible feature?
>> It may not be customer-visible, I, and, and ideally it, it could be, right?
And in other product line work it is the unit of visib,
of the unit is customer-visible feature.
In our case, it's more implementation centric.
But, but still, it's, it's much more on the science side than,
then the customer side so in our case, we, we're doing forecasting.
And there are some pretty com, complicated algorithmics that go with,
with forecasting.
So that domain is the domain at which we've we've done the future analysis.